coucou les putschistes étaient pas
sioniste hausse
vous l'avez voulue et bien vous l'avez
eue premier tuto ce but est pour je ne
sais pas peut-être un jour être comme
moi allez tout de suite les accessoires
waouh lots gloria de leurs mots styles
et pour ce premier tweet hausse
il faut quoi un boy's walkom mikami
ngaladio vieux revolver
allez c'est parti pour ce premier tu
t'es aux beautés on attaque avec la
crème des prénoms camille bellagio allez
c'est parti on y va on n'a pas peur on
applique généreusement 1 ou là là on y
va et on remonte on remonte très
important contre la gravité on remonte
contre la gravité et on tapote ouais on
tapote pour tout ce que je vois je vois
ce que j'aime
voilà bravo monkam de leurs moustaches
deuxième et accessoires très important
la pince à épiler pareil quand on se
regarde le style tac tac tac
ouais de leurs moustaches et pendant que
les crèmes applique qu est-ce qu on
ferme perd jamais son temps un beau
visage mais aussi un beau fessier aller
entre tourne et on le bot ce fait si on
le boss on l'aisne en laine c'est son
meilleur ami et voilà qui rit mort au
style jeu tekken de l'homme au style
vous avez la crème vous avez la pince à
épiler
vous avez la volonté alors c'est parti
j'appelle ma gloria où elle comme ma
belle
on y va 3 2 1 c'est parti
taylor
m
[Musique]
non
les boys
regardez gloria avant et regardez le
maintenant voilà c'était le premier
plutôt ce de te lire mon style
et n'oubliez pas le montrait beaucoup
plus beau si il ressemblait à moi